you still you go to as many ranger games
as you want oh yeah they give they give
us tickets why is that big so power is
like a staple new york show like when
i'm in america when you're in new york
people recognize insane i can't even
walk to the gym in the morning like i
work out you know kind of ten blocks
from where i am it's insane i can't walk
down are you serious put a hood on cause
i'm like this is crazy when i get in la
no one gives a [ __ ] i mean it's still a
huge fan base but it's also la so no one
cares anyways but when i'm in new york
like i can't go anywhere how how many
followers do you have now i don't even
know like six hundred thousand yeah
something how much what's what's your uh
instagram
it's at gianni v paolo
i'm telling you i looked on there one
day and it was like you had 30 000
followers and it seems like the next day
you had six hundred and something yeah
it was after season two of ghost when i
just started you know really being were
you just going crazy like oh my god look
at all these people following me yeah i
mean we also had like this little back
and forth where with um you know that
guy that went crazy viral it's the uh
50s other show called black mafia family
bmf it's on stars and all those guys
were um [ __ ] on our show so we
started [ __ ] on their show on social
media so then the shade room picked it
up like what do you mean [ __ ] on
your show like they would just be like
oh uh we have the number one rated show
which isn't true we have the number one
rated show on stars um
but so they started like tagging us and
all this stuff and then everything just
went crazy viral like the shade room
picked it up entertainment tonight
picked it up like all this stuff picked
it up and i remember like i got i think
i got like 100 000 that day or something
have you ever missed smallville
[Music]
no really i mean it was a big part of my
life our life
okay i mean you ever feel like watching
an old episode and talking about stuff
you know
no no
never well would you would you do it for
me
no would you do it for the fans
[Music]
yeah why not
be fun
join tom welling and michael rosenbaum
every week as they rewind every episode
of smallville and discuss their
experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast